le tribunal de paris a condamné
aujourd'hui onze personnes à des peines
de prison avec sursis quatre à six mois
dans la ferme il a vous avez cette jeune
fille qui avaient été poursuivis
harcelés sur les réseaux sociaux après
la publication alors il ya eu deux
affaires en fait les condamnations
d'aujourd'hui font suite à la
publication d'une vidéo par mila en
novembre dernier elle a eu selon son
avocat me richard malka
plus de cent mille messages de haine et
ces condamnations sont peut-être un peu
indulgente même si elle était conforme
au réquisitoire du ministère public
écoutez pour commencer la vie de la
principale intéressée mais il a
aujourd'hui au tribunal
je m'attendais à bien tirer et
honnêtement on a gagné et on gagnerait
encore parce que ce que je veux c'est
que tous ensemble on n'arrête jamais de
baisser les bras qu'on continue de se
battre
ce que je veux c'est que les personnes
qui seraient considérés comme des
pestiférés à qui on interdirait les
réseaux sociaux ce soit ceux qui
harcèlent qui prive de la liberté des
gens ce qui menace de mort ce qui incite
au suicide et je veux plus jamais qu'on
fasse culpabiliser les victimes
et comme je le dis dans mon livre force
à nous c'est tout voilà nous avons posé
la question sur twitter à vous même qui
est en train de nous suivre le jugement
rendu dans le procès milla est il trop
clément vous nous répondez oui à presque
80 % voici quelques points de vue celui
de caruso sur youtube
il n'y a pas eu de punition pour
l'exemple la seule chose qui en ressort
ce que l'on risque presque rien pour
avoir insulté harcelés et appeler au
meurtre une personne séverine sur
youtube une punition pour l'exemple
aurait permis de mettre les points sur
les i
et puis
london london underground pardon sur
youtube avec le contexte actuel et les
fanatiques de leur vision un peu partout
j'imagine que cette jeune fille savait à
quoi elle pouvait s'exposer en publiant
ses phrases publiquement avant
d'entendre votre point de vue je vous
propose d'écouter celui d'arnaud dhinaut
art c'est l'avocat d'un des prévenus
dans le procès milla et il explique
pourquoi ces peines ont pu paraître
comme étant indulgente
ce sont des primo délinquants et donc on
ne peut pas condamner très lourdement
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais été condamné
auparavant
c'est quand même important et puis
effectivement j'ai cru entendre que la
victime
milla estime elle que les peines étaient
peut-être un peu légère on a pu
l'entendre effectivement au cours du
délibéré
mais c'est un sentiment compréhensible
mais encore une fois ce sont des primo
délinquants et je trouve que pour une
première
le tribunal a fait oeuvre de pédagogie
en condamnant mais pas de manière
délibérée enfin pas trop fortement
battu ce cas ça vous paraît équilibré ce
jugement je suis pas juriste je suis ni
avocat ni ni magistrat donc je ne sais
rien je retiens juste que comme vous le
disiez vous même bio ça correspondait en
fait aux réquisitions du ministère
public et un tout petit peu de recul il
s'agit effectivement d'un de deux
messages postés sur les réseaux sociaux
alors il s'agit pas du tout de
relativiser le nuancier quoi que ce soit
mais je trouve que un message sur un
réseau social
quel qu'en soit le contenu ce qui se
traduit de menaces de mort oui oui alors
avec beaucoup de bêtises aussi et
dignard 10 confirmée en est et j'ai
l'impression par les témoignages à la
barre des différents prévenus on n'avait
pas en face de nous des radicaliser sûrs
de leur affaire
on s'est rendu compte qu'on avait une
adolescente peut-être pas très mûre elle
même dans son premier message à laquelle
répondait en fait des adolescents ou
post adolescents voilà pour le court
encore plus idiot enfin pardon pour ce
terme qui constitue un jugement de
valeur mais je sais pas si on peut
vraiment je suis un peu embarrassé en
fait dans la lecture qu'on fait de ce
procès comme d'un procès absolument
emblématique autour de fractures de la
société free tic qui qui qui viendraient
effectivement diviser la société
française bon j'ai l'impression que plus
exactement on se pose la question de la
régulation d'un nouveau média
qui constitue une caisse de résonance
inédite inédite encore une fois par le
par l'effet démultiplicateur qui est le
sien et voilà on dit beaucoup de bêtises
sur les réseaux sociaux et on se rend
compte à travers ce procès que quand on
dit des bêtises qu'ils peuvent avoir
effectivement un caractère dangereux
derrière on peut être condamné à de la
prison la prison ferme
il s'agit de deux jeunes personnes de 20
ans qui effectivement jusqu'à présent
n'avaient rien n'avait rien à se
reprocher ou en tout cas auquel la
justice n'avait rien à reprocher et qui
se trouve quand même avec un casier
judiciaire qui n'est plus vite désormais
qui n'est plus vierge loin de là ils ont
plaidé la bêtise la colère l'absence de
réflexion le risque jérôme sainte marie
c'est peut-être que avec ses peine
relativement légère avec du sursis
l'idée infuse dans l'opinion que
finalement c'est pas si grave de de
mener une campagne violente avec des
menaces de mort sur les réseaux sociaux
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas que les
peines soient particulièrement légère
par rapport aux faits précis on confond
l'émotion qu'on ressent en voyant cette
jeune femme dont la vie est abîmée pour
le moins pour kung fu et on a tous le
contexte à l'esprit et donc on aimerait
que ça n'existe pas ce genre de choses
et donc on aimerait que la justice
frappe très fort mais ce n'est pas
l'objet d' injustice j'ai regardé
attentivement quand même je suis pas
juriste non plus mais effectivement les
considérations des considérants du
jugement
c'est très précis c'est très
personnalisés certains ont eu plus
d'autres ont eu moins certain quelqu'un
été relaxé ce que c'était pas très clair
c'est ça la justice
alors je sais que maintenant dans
l'habitude de commenter les décisions de
justice sans aucun problème c'est la
sphère sauvage cette affaire halimi et
c'est que on se moque qu'on attaque les
magistrats parce que on demande aux
magistrats de régler des problèmes de
société ils sont là pour
on a été sur l'examen avec un regard
critique sur l'affairé que je pense est
légitime
faire la limite c'était quelque chose
quand même non j'avais c'était justifié
à mon avis enfin je pense que si nous
les médias nous nous faisons pas l'écho
de la colère du peuple français je te
parle pas spécifiquement sur ce cas et
par exemple sur l' affaire halimi vous
avez quand même les milliers de
personnes qui sont descendues de voulait
on ne veut pas que se taire les médias
depuis cette affaire ne sont pas faits
l'écho de toutes les personnes qui n'ont
pas été jugés parce qu'elles avaient
commis des crimes atroces
en situation de défense ça les médias
n'en parlent pas et moi du coup je suis
attentif à ça depuis cette affaire ça
n'arrête pas en réalité c'est comme ça
c'est la justice il ya des règles encore
une fois le sait tant mieux je savais
qu'il y avait un débat si vous voulez
qu'a été lancée la loi soit modifiée
mais enfin il ya aussi beaucoup de
bêtises qui ont été dites à ce moment là
je crois mais toujours revenir cette
affaire précise
là c'est un petit peu c'est pour ça que
ce parallèle comme la pour la faire
sauvage où on avait tout mélanger le
débat de société etc et la faire
elle-même l'a de nouveau on se retrouve
je sens qu'on a la tentation de dire
c'est pas assez sévères non il ya un
problème d'islamisme en france il ya un
problème la vie à ce genre de problème
mais là on jugeait des gens des
adolescents qui pour la première fois
avait fait de cet îlot sera face était
en train de se laisser entraîner à dire
des bêtises n'avait pas de lien avec
l'islam par exemple c'était pas du tout
une action concertée si vous voulez de
chasse à l'homme dirigé contre cette
personne c'est des gens qui par bêtise
par faiblesse et cetera france à moi ils
trouvent que je viens souvent les
réseaux sociaux et des gens très
respectables d'un certain âge qui
écrivent beaucoup de bêtises et qui
s'insultent sur les réseaux sociaux
donc on voit bien si vous voulez que la
des adolescents et en face ils ont quoi
ils ont quand même ils ont qu à de la
prison avec sursis c'est pas si fréquent
que ça vous savez en france à savoir si
ils ont des amendes
ils ont eu ce procès c'est un bel
avertissement quand vous voyez alors
apprécié y avait récidivé évidemment
l'une par le sursis tomberait est tout à
fait autre chose
par ailleurs parce que sinon il faut à
ce moment-là envoyé 100 mille personnes
en prison parce que s'il ya eu cent
mille messages de l'iton donc à ce
moment là il faudrait envoyer 100 mille
personnes en prison à tulle bat vous
rendez compte de ce qu'il faut faire
pour aller en prison en france
aujourd'hui est donc là moi ça me paraît
d'ailleurs j'ai l'impression que pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de polémique qui
part j'allais regarder différents mais
compris des médias ou des sites qui
soutiennent largement cette jeune femme
qui est très motivé pour l'instant j'ai
pas vu que ça me susciter une quelconque
comme on irait
une quelconque colère encore une fois il
s'agit d'individus qui sont jugés par
des magistrats par rapport à des textes
de loi et par rapport à un acte cet axe
c'est d'avoir et écrire des insanités
dirigée contre une personne
alors quand on se met du coup voilà mais
ça c'est uniquement ça c'est encore une
fois ça ne s'est pas une justice pour
l'exemple
voilà on change complètement notre
vision du droit et on considère qu'il ya
des justices condat faire des choses
pour l'exemple bon ben ça arrive il ya
des gens qui sont condamnés pour
l'exemple
je pense à les anciens présidents de la
république qui sont condamnés lourdement
et les magistrats disent ben voilà on en
est c'est pour faire un exemple
je suis pas je pense qu'on a besoin du
même avis sur le fond de cette affaire
auquel vous faites allusion mais en
l'occurrence à nicolas sarkozy clerc
mais là l'idée c'était que sedan ce
jugement que je trouve qui m'a laissé
songeur moi aussi mais l'ère du mois
était de dire que puisqu'il avait été
présent la république il devait être
parfaitement exemplaire
là on n'a pas convient que ce n'est pas
le même profil n'a pas faire des prêts
des présents de la république c'est moi
compris lorsque les réquisitions ont été
suivies
je devrai c'était compliqué peut-être
mathieu soupire c'est que effectivement
j'entends vos arguments et donc d'un
côté bon on va y aller il ya d'aider des
personnes condamnées qui qui vont
pouvoir continuer à vivre et c'est tant
mieux sans doute pour elle et de l'autre
côté il ya mille à qui elle j'entende je
lisais quelque part qu'elle pouvait même
pas avoir un chien parce que sinon ça
voulait dire qu'elle qu'il fallait le
sortir et qu'elle risquait d'être père
et je me verse et c'est ça qui est
terrible cette espèce de de déséquilibre
entre d'un côté à un très grand nombre
de gens qui repris individuellement ont
peut-être pas fait des choses
gravissimes et de l'autre côté une jeune
fille dans la vie est foutue
oui encore une fois c'est vraiment la
question de la régulation de
l'expression sur un média qui à
l'ampleur d'un réseau social
on n'a jamais connu ça en fait c'est
encore une fois les réseaux sociaux ça
produit le meilleur sur un partage
d'informations
un des intérêts des interactions entre
les gens qui peuvent plus dire des
choses très positives
on n'a jamais été aussi informés grâce
aux réseaux sociaux qu'aujourd'hui mais
on n'a jamais été autant désinformées à
cause des réseaux sociaux qu'aujourd'hui
donc le verre est à moitié vide et à
moitié plein et on cherche des éléments
de régulation pour arriver à faire de
cet outil
quelque chose qui soit conforme à ce qui
était sa promesse initiale
voilà vous
c'est moi mathieu mais je crois que vous
mélanger deux choses il ya effectivement
la question de la circulation
d'informations sur les réseaux sociaux
je sais qu'il ya des organismes qui
rêvent de supprimer tout cela et qui
veut le faire comme en images qui
parlent sans cesse de fake news etc
puis après on se rend compte parfois il
ya playfect nous autres de guilherme son
prix l'effectif aujourd'hui si pour les
jeunes notamment pour la faire le vide
et mais ça ça pour ça comme je suis
totalement pour la liberté totale
d'expression sur internet contrairement
peut-être à d'autres mais là c'est autre
chose c'est pas des fausses informations
c'est pas des paniers polémique etc
c'est une aide ciblée sur une personne
n'a rien à voir non non c est là
effectivement c'est des menaces il ya un
truc concret mais si vous voulez pour
qu'on jouera je comprends très bien
parfait je suis moi même un peu partagé
face à ce jugement parce que
effectivement on est un peu déçu mais
c'est pas en s'acharnant sur des gens
qui ont fait des bêtises qu'on résoudra
le problème de l'islamisme en france
dire qu'on fasse appliquer les lois
précisément la loi est appliquée ce qui
est peut-être dommage c'est que la loi
ne soit pas appliquée pour dans toute
une série de domaines qui sont un peu
connexes et donc effectivement mais
c'est ça c'est jérôme c'est quand même
davantage le procès de la bêtise que le
procès de l'islamisme en l'occurrence
c'est encore une fois elle s'est fait
insulter
cent mille messages aux bêtas cent mille
messages au total beaucoup ont un
caractère précisément homophobes que le
sujet c'est pas qu'elle est parlée en
fait de l'islam c'est qu'elle ait fait
état du fait qu'elle était lesbienne au
premier afin de camer vidéo en janvier
2000 et est encore une fois sur les
douze ou treize prévenus je sais pas
seuls deux avaient un rapport avec
l'islam
il ya même un de ceux qui a été le plus
lourdement condamné en fait et
catholique revendique en fait son
appartenance à la communauté catholique
donc je suis pas sûr que dans cette
affaire il ya un lien direct à faire à
l'islamisme et je rebondis sur ce que je
disais moi même en fait c'est il ya bien
deux éléments internet est une source
d'informations et donc aujourd'hui une
source d'information mais aussi un
formidable vecteur d'expression et
comment est ce qu'on fait pour que cette
expression soit totalement libre et en
même temps régulier puisque encore une
fois les messages de haine s'échangent
enfin je veux dire
j'imagine que vous deux comme moi quand
vous passez sur des médias pas le figaro
là il n'y en a entendu puisque le les
spectateurs sont des gens extrêmement
civilisé mais je passe régulièrement sur
des chaînes d'information après chaque
passage on après chaque passage sur les
réseaux sociaux
je me fais insulter voire menacés donc
je veux dire est normal que la plupart
des gens n'ont pas la chance de pouvoir
s'exprimer
les jeunes comme nous je ne vais
sûrement victime je constate ce fait je
constate ce fait et je dis que nous
avons à travailler collectivement à une
juste régulation en fait de ce
formidable vecteur d'expression
ça s'appelle de la censure juste
régulation c'est la censure non je crois
pas il ya des choses il ya des choses
qui étaient permises il y à quelques
décennies qu'aujourd'hui effectivement
on interdit sont pour autant pouvoir
dire qu on a basculé dans un système de
censure vous regardiez que la liberté au
mont sainte marie tant pis il faut vivre
avec y compris avec ce genre de campagne
mais le rapport à où bien sûr main sur
le rapport avec moi je conçois juin je
trouve que vend la liberté d'expression
sur internet comme toute liberté
d'expression d'ailleurs est tout à fait
salutaire et qu'ils en trouvent tous
dans l'information qu'on ne trouve pas
ailleurs
moi je m'en félicite si on compare notre
ce que l'on avait bon et par ailleurs
les fêtes nous c'est pas faux autrefois
pour des libéraux si vous voulez c'est
l'effectif de mensonges il venait du
pouvoir il pouvoir
là on considère qu'il vient de la base
très bon je m'en souviens d'un peu
partout mais est-ce que je pense
qu'effectivement les gens ont le droit
de s'exprimer et ont droit d'exprimer
des messages extrêmement dure tant que
ça reste un certain niveau de généralité
lorsque ça devient et là on change ça ne
change de nature cela c'est une menace
sur une personne et là où
malheureusement il ya un rapport avec
islamisme et islam
c'est que 6,7 on a peur pour la vie de
cette jeune femme et si elle a peur pour
sa vie
c'est bien parce qu'on pense à des
assassinats justifiait justement enfin
commis par des islamistes
celle ci se serait autre chose on alors
elle aurait subi si vous voulez un
lynchage virtuelle sur internet c'est
pas agréable mais ce n'était pas le fond
ce n'est pas le fond de la faire là on
se dit mais est ce que il n'ya pas
passer à l'acte bien sûr un déséquilibré
comme on dit désormais mais tous chacun
sait ce que ça signifie et bien un
supposé délit il va passer à l'acte
c'est çà et là c'est un rapport avec
tous ces attentats que subit l'europe
depuis un certain temps donc c'est là où
il ya un pas que l'islamisme mais encore
une fois le problème de l'islamisme les
problèmes connexes à l'islamisme les
causes de cette menace islamiste en
france
la tienne à la non application est un
ensemble de lois beaucoup plus qu'au
manque de commandes ira jusqu'à la 30ème
et et de justice voilà c'est dit et vous